las consecuencias de los últimos ataques
rusos contra kiev Aunque Ucrania afirma
que sus defensas aéreas interceptaron
los 10 misiles balísticos y de crucero y
scandard los restos que cayeron dañaron
edificios residenciales una guardería y
una clínica matando a varias personas
entre ellas una menor
hubo una alerta aérea la gente corría al
Refugio fue largo mi mujer y mi hijo
estaban allí El niño está bien pero mi
mujer murió
yo había ido al lado opuesto para
preguntar sobre la apertura del Refugio
en ese momento ocurrió
un en vivo corrían hacia aquí para
esconderse pero estaba cerrado por
desgracia estábamos fuera cayó justo
entre la policlínica y la guardería
[Música]
el ataque del jueves por la mañana fue
el décimo octavo la capital ucraniana
desde principios de mayo
Moscú ha intensificado sus ataques con
misiles y drones mientras kiev se
prepara para lanzar una contraofensiva
una táctica que según analistas pretende
agotar las defensas aéreas ucranianas
que necesitan munición Mientras tanto el
crimen acusa a kiev de intensificar los
ataques en las zonas fronterizas rusas
el miércoles el gobernador de belgorot
anunció que evacuarían a los niños de la
región tras el mortífero ataque de
principios de semana dos personas más
resultaron heridas en belgorosa a
primera hora del jueves en el último
ataque atribuido por Rusia a las tropas
ucranianas